[Music]
so is this Runway casting for a grumpy
brand or a smiley brand
so it's a grumpy brand yeah
congratulations show me that Balenciaga
look
suddenly I'm dressed in something way
less expensive
it's h m yeah
it looks paid for the tickets not bad
huh yeah sure yeah I did
the success of luxury Cruise mainly
depends on you
I don't want to hear anybody saying no
it's always yes sir yes ma'am
I command you enjoy the moment
no no no what
you say no to me no no so it's yes yes
no yes oh yeah yes
the Saints do you think it's possible to
wash them
I don't think that's possible man
because this is a motorized vessel yeah
so we don't have any sales
people say yes
well then in that case
we will clean the sails yes of course
yes
[Music]
Russian capitalists
and an American Communist on a 250
million dollar luxury
the ship is going under
[Music]
[Applause]
is really bad
this is really really bad
[Music]